ils sont venus exprimer leur colère et
leur ras-le-bol face aux incohérences
autour du nouveau protocole sanitaire
enseignants retraités de l'éducation
nationale ou encore parents d'élèves ils
étaient près de 40 devant la
sous-préfecture de mantes-la-jolie ce
mardi alors qu'une délégation était
reçue par le sous préfet le constat
c'est que chacun se débrouille avec les
moyens du bord et ça ça me pose un vrai
problème parce que on connaît la
pandémie depuis le mois de mars et que à
mon sens toutes les mesures depuis
confinement elles sont au coup par coup
dans l'urgence et il n'ya pas
d'anticipation sur la gestion du temps
scolaire en tant que maman d'élève
on demande à ce qu'il y ait une
réorganisation des espaces des lieux les
travaux nécessaires pour qu'il y ait
suffisamment de sanitaires pour le
lavage des mains des masques gratuits
pour les enfants les parents d'élèves
souhaitent surtout le maintien de
l'école au quotidien pour les
professeurs malgré les nouveaux
protocoles peu de changements sont
visibles hier j'étais dans une petite
salle de la halle et 40 mètres carrés
maximum et
j'ai j'avais une face à 29 élèves voilà
donc tous entassés des élèves de 3e des
costauds un d'écran et à peine la
possibilité de circuler
l'heure suivante les élèves partaient
dans une salle de physique en salle
spécifique et c'est un 2002 classe un
regroupement de deux classes qui venait
dans la salle où j'étais donc voilà le
brassage il est là une situation à
laquelle tous souhaitent mettre un terme
et enseigner dans de meilleures
conditions
pendant l'entretien le sous préfet
semble avoir écouté attentivement la
délégation il a dit qu'il ferait
remonter ces informations